bonsoir et bienvenue en kiosque que
votre magazine culturel un kiosque
largement consacrée à la fête de la
musique
la fête de la musique assez le 21 juin
34e édition et on accueille sur ce
plateau quatre invités catherine iata
bonsoir vous êtes maire adjointe
déléguée à la culture un voisin le
bretonneux à vos côtés marquisat cow
boys wars coordinateur du pôle musique
et théâtre en charge des musiques
amplifiées à montigny en face de vous
jean pierre pierre bonsoir bonsoir
patrick et de guyancourt et j'en adrian
bon soit il est chargé de mission
jeunesse à la ville de versailles
organisateurs et programmateur des
vendredis du rock alors vous allez nous
décrire ce que l'on peut écouter
entendre et voir dans vos communes
respectives on a commencé par les femmes
honneur aux femmes à voisins le
bretonneux tout va se passer autour de
l'espace de covile ce sera dimanche 21
juin c'est important de le préciser
parce que à guyancourt ce sera samedi
en l'occurrence un voisin ce sera
dimanche qu'est ce qu'on pourra entendre
c'est vraiment la place donnée aux
groupes locaux tout à fait donc à
voisins la ville organise en fait la
fête de la musique en association avec
des principales les principaux groupes
chinois ou aux alentours donc c'est une
entre guillemets coproduction entre la
ville et l'association met ta sauce qui
fait toutes les prestations techniques
qui s'occupe de musique amplifiée en
temps en temps normal en fait et nous
avons dans l'espace culturel decauville
une programmation très variée en fait
puisque on commence vers 16h par monte
en douceur on commence par du piano
ensuite on fait de la baisse vers voilà
tout à fait et ces grands élèves dont la
fille donc j'espère qu'elle sera au haut
niveau
elle est juste maintenant vous devez
surveiller pas elle avait trop stressé
non je vois pas là c'est trop tard non
en fait on varie en fait tu nous fais
une alternance donc dans la maison de
kovy enfin dans la cour de covile entre
la scène qui est sûre paieront donc
devant la maison et puis des scènes qui
sont dispersés un petit peu partout donc
en commençant par de classiques on
alterne ensuite avec la flûte
traversière va remanier saint quentin et
l'ensemble donc de francis pas la mare
dessus bien connu le petit atelier
lyrique et ensuite on va aller enchaîné
sur des trucs un peu plus gérer une
musique plus actuelle avec aussi un
intermédiaire de danse puisque nous
avons illicites qui va nous faire une
telle prestation
et la chose à noter aussi c'est que ce
week-end à voisins nous fêtons les 10
ans de notre acte et d'amitié avec
earvin donc une une ville écossaise donc
nous avons nous avons deux groupes
écossais alors je ne sais pas s'ils vont
jouer en kilt ou pas mais nous avons
deux groupes et que c'est qu'ils nous
font l'honneur de jouer donc c'est
plutôt de la musique traditionnelle
d'après ce que j'ai compris
on est très heureux de les accueillir
l'occasion de cette fête de la musique
justement en parlant de de musique
notamment de musique amplifiée à la
politique de la ville en la matière est
ce que vous proposez des studios de
répétition tout à fait donc nous avons
des signaux de répétition et qui sont
délégués en gestion donc justement mais
ta sauce et donc tous les sites ouverts
a pas simplement envie sinon en mai à
toute la ville nouvelle et même je
dirais on a des groupes qui viennent de
toute l'île de france et même hors de
l'ile-de-france communes limitrophes et
le parti pris la ville donc et d'ouvrir
ses studios et de faire tous les mois un
concert en fait de musiques amplifiées
dans dans la salle de la tour pour
pouvoir permettre aux groupes locaux et
- locaux de se produire devant un public
donc l'arrêt de la musique à voisins le
bretonneux ce sera dimanche à partir de
16h avec la fille le bretonneux
on va passer à montigny le bretonneux ça
sera aussi dimanche ça sera aussi à
partir de 16 heures
j'ai rappelé au même endroit sap à
l'espace de huit puisque c'est un voisin
ça sera ouverte aux blacks
voilà aussi les groupes locaux on part
de la couldre et c'est effectivement
100% unis montrent un et donc on va
commencer à 16 heures
en gros entre 16h et 18h ce serait des
groupes des ateliers du conservatoire de
musique avec des chorales unis montrent
elles aussi
puis à partir de 18 heures jusqu'à 23
heures
des groupes de musiques amplifiées
accompagné par le cema et donc par la
ville avec un groupe une parenthèse qui
est un groupe qui n'est pas accompagnée
par la ville mais qui est un groupe qui
vient de denton qui était jumelée avec
la ville de montigny un groupe qui
s'appelle dirty breivik
voilà en poupe et en tout ira 12 groupes
est ce qu'une sélection pour les gros
pour vous accueillez tous les groupes
qui soit participer à la fête de la
musique
alors on peut pas accueillir tout le
monde est ce qu'on est sûr et prudemment
mais il ya beaucoup de demande
effectivement et on est obligé de faire
un choix on essaie aussi de faire
participer des inimités qui n'avait pas
eu l'occasion encore de participer à la
fête de la musique
et puis on présente aussi le travail qui
a été fait toute l'année dans le cadre
de l'accompagnement qu'on propose aux
coups fumants tu as donc il ya deux
semaines il y aura deux seront passés
d'une saint malo exactement ça va jouer
en alternance les gens pour se restaurer
s'il fait très beau se reposer sur la
pelouse et voilà au rythme des mélodies
et même question qu'à 80 dates a donc le
secteur des musiques amplifiées qu'est
ce que la ville de montigny propose pour
les groupes locaux tout au long de
l'année
là on a deux yeux de répétition et un
studio d'enregistrement et on propose
aux groupes
il ya des résidences on organise des
clubs jazz
démont qui live avec des rencontres
entre des artistes professionnels et
donc des artistes
le cours est
des scènes ouvertes qui vont revenir
aussi donc voilà on n'essaye pas mal pas
mal de d'enregistrement qui est un
exercice très intéressant pour les
groupes pour se perfectionner et
découvrir l'environnement d'un studio
d'enregistrement et donc être un peu
plus crédible et à 20 meilleure assise
auprès des ensuite des professionnels
privés donc ça c'est donc ce que fait la
ville de montigny pendant toute l'année
pour les musiques amplifiées et donc
pour la fête de la musique c'est
dimanche à 16 heures au château d'eau au
parc du château de la cool avec deux
scènes on pourra voir les groupes locaux
sont claires pia la direction cours vos
amis en cours c'est à peu près la même
chose sauf que c'est le samedi soir
oui savoir est 18 heures mais c'est
aussi la place aux groupes locaux
absolument dont la batterie serait de
samedi soir dans la continuité de d'une
opération qui s'appelle quartiers en
fête à guyancourt
donc c'est à partir de 18 heures et puis
on donc on investit toute la batterie
avec six plateaux les six plateaux
présentent tous styles de musique
ça va vraiment de la musique classique
baroque jusqu'au jusqu'au métal en
passant par le folk rock est aussi oui
oui donc comme d'habitude à la batterie
c'est très très très éclectique et
surtout ses simultanée se faire que sur
le même moment on peut passer d'une
musique à l'autre voilà selon ses goûts
selon son envie du moment
donc ça va s'enchaîner comme ça pendant
qu'elle soit de 18 ans jusqu'après
minuit avant minuit alors une
quarantaine de groupes un peu plus de
200 personnes 200 musiciens invités
les formats est très différent puisque
musique classique on peut avoir des
ensembles enfin c'est conséquent
jusqu'au simple duo folk qui vient jouer
et c'est des groupes qui répètent au
sein de la batterie nous faisons chaque
année un appel à candidatures pour
pouvoir venir sur de la prestation de la
batterie
malheureusement on n'a pas assez de
place pour tout le monde on essaie de
faire une programmation qui se
renouvelle à chaque fois et notre
programmation prend en compte 50 % de
personnes qui sont issus de l'activité
de la batterie à toute l'année c'est à
l'issue de nos studios de répétition et
puis des groupes que l'on que l'on
côtoie très régulièrement
et puis 50 % viennent de l'extérieur du
territoire
voilà d'accord merci jean pierre pierre
donc fête de la musique c'est au samedi
soir à la batterie à guillon qu'on va
finir avec versailles jean veillon donc
bon soir
alors là vous c'est autant toute la
ville de versailles
pratiquement aucun cas sa part de la
place notre dame jusqu'à la place
exactement voilà on fait avec ce qu'on a
on déploie effectivement ce sera
dimanche ce sera dimanche soir bal à
partir de leurs 17 heures et donc on
aura cette ya un axe musicale en fait
une voie musicale qui se déploie de la
place du marché notre dame jusqu'au
jusqu'à la cathédrale saint louis et
tout au long de cet axe vous avez en
un panel de musiciens hostiles au style
aussi riche que varié qui se voit que se
déploie le long de cet axe avec
notamment à la dcn qui met en avant
certaines formations plutôt jeunes
plutôt locales qui sont très
talentueuses
si on pouvait en retenir trois
d'ailleurs je me permettrai de les citer
mais vous avez à 20h notamment place du
marché une jeune femme s'appelle
clarisse qui est une jeune versaillaise
qui a participé à la nouvelle star cette
année qui est très très talentueuse qui
est seul sur scène avec son piano qui
chante vient de sortir son premier
premier rhdp ça sera l'un des moments
forts en ouverture de cette de la soirée
vous allez un petit peu plus tard sur le
parking de l'europe
un dj qui s'appelle jimmy qui lui aussi
est versailles et 10000 étaient venus
une première fois la fête de la musique
à deux ans il était inconnu il qu'en
début de soirée le personne ne le
connaissez et deux ans plus tard c'est
un dj les plus demandés il fait des
tournées dans toute l'europe
il s'est vidé au fond des millions de
vues et joue notamment avec 1
avec un saxophoniste houssaye de deep
house avec un saxophoniste est très
agréable à écouter c'est très plaisant
même pour ceux qui ne sont pas
spécialement fan de ce type de musique
c'est dansant et puis ces épices et
symphonique avec ceux avec cette belle
association auprès de benjamin lacoste
le saxophoniste donc ça c'est à partir
de 22 heures sur le parking de l'europe
plutôt électro et puis en fin de soirée
à 23 heures vous avez le vainqueur et
des vendredis du rock c'est parce que y
circule ce qui est un groupe extrêmement
tortueux qui était lauréat des du du
ricard sa live est qui et qui est un
groupe prometteur keira qui a gagné sept
éditions 2015 des randonnées du rock et
qui clôturera sur la place du marché
cette cette édition de la fête de la
musique également à versailles comme
dans les autres communes
une dernière juste question ces jeux
prévu une forte mobilisation d'avant
beaucoup de bénévoles beaucoup
d'associations beaucoup de bénévoles qui
sont sollicités pour cette fête de la
wii absolument y aller il à la fois des
services techniques aussi qu'ils sont
mobilisés qu'il faut remercier parce
qu'ils sont sur le pont du samedi
0 heure au dimanche minuit et même le
lundi matin
et puis un nombre d'aces de
effectivement d'associations de
bénévoles des gens qui s'impliquent de
tout au long de deux semaines dans les
autres villes aussi bénévole aussi
beaucoup et le bénévolat et les services
techniques effectivement qu'il faut
remercier parce que sans lui on pourrait
absolument rien faire merci en tout cas
où quatre d'être venu rapidement mais ça
peut être autre chose que nous présenter
votre fête de musique à vous donc en
général ces deux dimanches sauf le
samedi soir vous des noter encore c'est
le samedi soir et je vous brosse
maintenant d'autres idées pour occuper
votre fête de la musique avant de
recevoir deux autres invités
où l'analyste
c'était rapide mais comme ça rahmani des
hameaux fête de la musique autour du
cristal baschet avec l'ensemble de
william byrd ce dimanche entre 15h et
17h au musée de port royal des champs
une soirée organisée par l'association
pour le rayonnement de port-royal
concert à retrouver également la veille
le samedi à 21h suivi d'un feu
d'artifice à elancourt rendez vous
dimanche à 17 heures à la maison de
quartier de la ville dieu la chorale
crescendo vous convie à la fête de la
musique c'est gratuit
la fête de la musique se conjuguent 4 ap
avec la fête de la ville des concerts de
groupes locaux seront proposés à partir
de 17 heures point fort de cette soirée
le concert de sinsemilia 21h38 d'un peu
d'artifices
que peut-on vous souhaiter tout le
bonheur du monde il mêle maire de
calmont
on souhaite tout le bonheur du monde
pour aujourd'hui comme pour demain de
votre soleil éclaire solution hybride
amour quotidien
amour pas le rendez vous est fixé ce
samedi à l'est de la côte d'or les
élèves du conservatoire de musique et
d'art dramatique se produiront de 10h à
10h30 puis les choeurs de la pléiade de
10h45 à 11 heures et encore le coeur
très chendo de 11h admis pour la
première fois la ville de bois d'arcy
organise la fête de la musique à la fin
de la tramblais ce samedi concert à
partir de 15h30 pour les plus jeunes dès
6 ans avec les courtes pattes
à noter à 20h45 le concert des killers
frogs et à partir de 21h30 un battle
entre les amateurs des rolling stones et
les beatles l'entrée est libre
et puis aux clayes-sous-bois la fête de
la musique s'appelle les clés si belle
un festival créé en 88 début des
concerts à 16 heures en vedette cette
année yannick noah 20h30 et ben l'oncle
soul à 22h30
l'entrée est libre je vous laisse avec
la bande annonce avant de retrouver de
nouveau invité
allez on continue cette émission on
accueille deux autres invités avaient
farges bonsoir ça on accueille maureen
dor jours merci beaucoup d'avoir à
répondre à notre invitation suis ravi
dimanche 21 juin c'est la fête de la
musique on en a largement parlé et à 18
heures au théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines y aura deux
cent quarante enfants issus des écoles
de trappes mendy elancourt qui vont
interpréter un excellent et gretel issu
du célèbre conte de grimm
ils vont se produira évidemment avec des
artistes professeurs dont vous et vous
expliquerez votre rôle qui peut être
étonnant qui on étendra peut-être je
crois un peu pas fait la farce au
spectacle lyrique qui est produit par
l'association pour la promotion de la
musique à 50 ans on y vit il dit en
parlant c'est vraiment la marque de
l'aboutissement d'un travail d'une année
oui c'est un travail de huit mois donc
les enfants les 240 enfants plus la
maîtrise de trappes en yvelines dont
leurs armées travaillent depuis le mois
de novembre
donc tous les shaks semaine il ya une
intervenante musicale qui vient leur
faire travailler le l'oeuvre qui a été
réécrite par lionel rougerie de metteur
en scène dont on va parler et est adapté
poil adapté et donc les enfants ont
appris par coeur le tout les airs et
maintenant ils travaillent sous la
direction de mélanie les tous ensemble
alors qu'elle se manifeste au donc de il
y aura cinquante quatre musiciens et
orchestres symphoniques qui vont les
accompagner au numéro d'un orchestre de
la maîtrise de la maîtrise de travail
gabriel abbad a réitéré ses
exceptionnelles et puis de se désister
alors on a la chance je sais pas lire
mais vraiment d'avoir maureen dor qui
latvala alors la bosnie qui joue alors
le rôle de gretel exactement indoors
jouer la sorcière
là on vous voit pas en sorcière dans les
scieries de tous aux sorcières j'ai fait
ça très bien alors vous êtes retrouvé
dans cet avant
part parce que le monde est petit et le
monde de la musique encore plus en fait
mélanie thibault la cheffe de leur
caisse manifesto j'ai travaillé avec
elle en belgique pour l'orchestré la
portée des enfants
c'est aussi qu'il ya un projet non c'est
pas du tout avec des enfants et donc ce
n'est pas aussi ambitieux parce que père
chantait 250 enfants c'est d'une
ambition incroyable fou incroyable en
plus des enfants qui à mon avis non pas
ça en famille si vous voulez si vous si
vous êtes dans certains milieux où on
vous dit oh mon fils ce parti de
maîtrise de paris effaçait le patio
n'est pas le cas ici c'est entre de
l'école imposé au juge des enfants - et
je peux vous dire j'ai assisté à la
première répétition avec les enfants il
ya deux gîtes ému par ce que vous allez
trouver justement homme et son
formidable parce que soyons quand même
clair c'est de l'opéra et c'est pas la
traviata ou que tout le monde connaît ce
sont des airs c'est une forme
d'exigences musical c'est je trouve
voilà qu'on n'en parle pas assez de
cette exigence qu'on peut avoir avec des
enfants qu'il faut avoir avec les
enfants et j'ai l'impression qu'on
entend toujours les lieux ou du panier
dit oui faisons un bac facile
faisons un truc facile les enfants dans
là c'est pas facile et on pas noël pour
chacun en fait pas mal à sa source et en
pologne
je pourrai alors qu'il vous comprenez et
c'est ça le truc est bien ce projet
prouve à ceux qui en douteraient et je
sais qu'il a beaucoup qui doute
j'aurais bien envie des invités mais on
est sold out complet complet complet
c'est super on ne peut venir à la
générale général alors même que la
générale c
c'est très samedi à 20h samedi à 20h30
sinon c'est dimanche à 18h à la banque
c'est bien mais c'est complet mais ces
volets ayant des ambitions et ce projet
le montre wahid et moi mon rôle c'est
juste d'être au niveau de leurs
ambitions
d'accord et on regarde un petit extra
est justement de niveau de l'ambition
des images fournies par donc le rôle de
la sorcière ça se passait une partie
voilà c'est qu'elle va se transformer
elle est comme il voit la vue une
sorcière elle se dit pour ne pas leur
faire peur alors que je me transforme en
belle fée qui ne leur fera pas peur
d'accord alors elle a tellement bien
joué que les enfants ne faisaient que la
regarder et se sont fait gronder par
mélanie parce qu'ici veut plus la chef
mais tâter de rire devant le jeune amant
vient de partager avec les enfants
ah oui vraiment vraiment vraiment et je
pense je suis certaine que le public
aura autant plaisir à les voir à nous
voir que nous avons
elle joue et pieroni fier merci à vous
d'être sur le plateau de kiosques lui
rajoute une chose sa vie le plus
important dans ce projet c'est donner
l'occasion aux enfants d'être fiers
d'eux quelque part quand les enfants
n'ont pas de hobby quand on leur fait
rien fait rien faire en dehors de
l'école ou parfois ça se passe plutôt
bien
on leur donne jamais l'occasion d'être
fiers de ce qu'ils font et ce genre de
projet leur donne au 10 mai at on peut
être fier de moi et ça en dehors de tout
c'est pour moi le plus grand service
qu'on puisse rendre à un enfant tous que
vous êtes une super ambassadrice de la
paix mais ce qu un iphone c'est trop
merci
merci beaucoup d'être venu sur papier
amaury est donc je précise que le
spectacle qui est gratuit est proposé
dimanche à 18h mais c'est complet mais
si vous voulez il ya la générale samedi
à caen qui vient toujours c'est donc
samedi à 20h30 sur la scène du théâtre
national merci beaucoup ont pas ce matin
la chronique de nicolas gerber le prisme
l encours présente sa nouvelle saison et
pour nous en parler sabine caussens la
semaine dernière c'était la scène
nationale mais cette semaine je me
demande bien ce qu'il y aura au prix de
la saison prochaine tu fais comme la
semaine dernière
tu demandes à la directrice sabine que
ça adacore une pluridisciplinarité
théâtre musique danse chanson quelques
nouveautés bien sûr on aura l'occasion
d'en reparler après on est toujours
engagé dans la parité hommes-femmes
puisque les femmes ont toujours un peu
de retard donc on donne un petit coup de
pouce voilà et puis très attaché au
spectacle à voir en famille se partage
entre parents enfants grands parents
enfants
dans le projet du prisme il ya des
danseurs qui sont associés danseur
chorégraphe et des compagnies donc
évidemment le public aura l'occasion non
seulement de venir voir leurs créations
mais aussi de pouvoir faire des
créations collectives avec le doc sont
nombreux ils sont cinq
quand même chorégraphe qui réside au
prisme dans les invités oui je pense
qu'on est très très contents
d'accueillir benjamin millepied benjamin
millepied c'est le directeur de la danse
à l'opéra de paris il a longtemps très
longtemps travaillé à los angeles où il
a sa compagne et la los angeles times
project et c'est avec cette compagnie
qui vient il nous propose trois pièces
une de lui donc de benjamin millepied
une de william forsythe célébrissime
chorégraphe et une pièce justin peck est
un jeune chorégraphe l'autre basse et le
fidèle complice de toujours c'est jean
claude gallotta voilà qui jean claude
gallotta avait très envie de créer
quelque chose à partir de l'étranger de
camus la création aura lieu à grenoble
la le 19 ou le 20 juin
de grands noms en théâtre oui oui 12 de
spectacles de théâtre donc évidemment
des spectacles à découvrir je vous en
parlerai après mais effectivement de
grands noms de grands noms d'interprètes
qui se sont attachés à des textes et
c'est très important alors le premier et
on ouvrira la saison le 3 octobre avec
philippe torreton qui a choisi de dire
des textes d'alain leprest pour redonner
vie
les force à ce frère de brel et de
ferrer qui dit rien qui s'étirait tout
va les payer
j'avais du gol maintenant et plus de moi
autre grand nom et ben le molière 2015
du théâtre public qui est andré
dussollier et andré dussolier a fait le
choix de jouer de collaborer à la mise
en scène du novecento c'est un enfant
qui est né sur un paquebot le virginia
on est en 1940 50 et il n'est jamais
descendu de ce panneau il n'y aura
grandi il deviendra le plus grand
pianiste de jazz du monde
voilà c'est le novecento et il y aura un
portait de jazz sur la scène et le soir
quelques fois on descendait tout en bas
sur le pont des troisièmes ont joué
comme ça que ça nous mais pour le
plaisir sans uniforme
pour les migrants qui joue avec nous et
aussi des coups de coeur oui toujours
toujours hélas il y en a deux ils sont
en théâtre d'ailleurs alors y en a un
tout premier c'est un spectacle qu'on
aura quatre représentations c'est dans
la petite salle de spectacle un peu
intime
lilith donc l'élite c'est la première
femme des femmes c'est la première que
dieu créa
mais elle n'a jamais vraiment au pays ni
à donner à personne parce qu'elle a sa
façon d'être indépendante et elle
deviendra la reine des sorcières et
c'est cette histoire que juliet or julie
parent dont les corps façon julie
recoins nous raconte ça c'est notre coup
de coeur jeudi le coup de coeur de
l'équipe du prix ce n'est pas que le
mien et l'autre est aussi intrigante
beaucoup de gars est l'adaptation d'un
texte classique andromaque jean racine
tout le monde connaît sauf que personne
ne comprendra jamais rien à ondres mac
et ses deux jeunes gens deux jeunes
comédiens ont décidé de tous nous rendre
simple
une scène pour le jazz au prisme alors
on ouvre avec un grand nom le géant de
la basse
markus müller donc il sera cet été dans
les plus grands festivals de jazz il est
un peu partout autre beau moment de
musique partagée entre un homme et une
femme
c'est fatoumata diawara et roberto
fonseca
alors ils arriveront ici à elancourt au
prix s'ajustent après leur concert à
paris à la villette
lui c'est le pianiste cubain de la
musique cubaine aujourd'hui le talent
tisdale en thueux et llm aliens et je
pense que les gens la connaissent
ciseaux vu le film timbuktu puisqu'elle
chante dedans
un jeune et talentueux thomas enhco qui
dans son récital de piano sur un travail
qu'il a composé autour de l'amour est
par contre un autre pianiste baptiste
trotignon qui est déjà venu ici et que
les voilà les grands amoureux de jazz de
connaissent et revient sa femme trio la
forme basique du jazz donc avec son
compère et complice de toujours thomas
bramerie à la contrebasse et avec jeff
ballard da la batterie qui a joué avec
les plus grands c'est un américain et on
est très contents de la voir le trio
rosenberg donc les frères rosenberg qui
nous arriverons de des pays bas je crois
en mes vives aux pays-bas et et du coup
ils ont l'habitude d'avoir des invités
alors vous choisissez et là j'ai choisi
sanseverino
collection
deux grands rendez vous d'humour
essentiellement les clown des clowns
russes qui sont de saint pétersbourg le
semianyki dès qu'une fou qui nous emmène
dans un train express et on passe du
voyageur au chef de gare aux contrôleurs
c'est du théâtre gestuel c'est une
grande famille de clowns et c'est du un
très bon moment assuré
et puis on finira finira la saison
dernier spectacle de la saison au niveau
avec stéphane guillon alors qu'il ne
revient très en forme et elle aussi elle
est toujours deux saisons c'est
catherine dans le kiosque et comme tous
les mercredis et la chronique cinéphiles
avec le coup de coeur d'un professionnel
du septième art ce soir cyril haddad des
clayes sous bois
cette semaine notre coup de coeur et le
film le labyrinthe du silence l'action
se déroule en allemagne en 1958 un jeune
procureur découvre des pièces
essentielles permettant l'ouverture d'un
procès contre d'anciens ss ayant servi à
auschwitz mais il doit faire face à de
nombreuses aux hostilités dans cette
allemagne d'après guerre déterminé il
fera tout pour que les allemands ne suis
pas leur passé le labyrinthe du silence
est inspiré de l'histoire vraie de fritz
bauer procureur général de francfort et
de trois procureurs travaillant pour lui
qui furent à l'origine du procès à
auschwitz qui se déroula dans les années
réalisé avec passion et conviction ce
film est d'autant plus impressionnant
qu'il s'agit d'un premier long métrage
formellement maîtrisé à travers une
reconstitution soignée
le cinéaste réussit un vrai tour de
force en présentant ce récit méconnus
comme un thriller palpitant
il s'en sort remarquablement bien en ne
filmant aucune reconstitution des camps
et des exactions commises le labyrinthe
du silence est proposé en version
originale cette semaine à l'espace
philippe noiret
je vais rester à l'une de ses choix et
les angevins
cette émission maintenant terminé merci
de l'avoir suivi rendez vous la semaine
prochaine